so it's another game day for degrom and
we will see if he's able to get through
this one still with a chance to win the
cy young award to graham's era 209 is 80
strikeouts still among the league
leaders in the national league he's
fifth right now in era and seventh in
strikeouts yoshitsugo we are ready for
baseball the first of three
and he takes care of tsutsuko on three
pitches the last one at a hundred miles
an hour and that's uh degrom's night
begins
one two coming and he strikes him out
with a hundred mile an hour fastball so
that's triple digit heat to strike at
each of the first two hitters
here's willie adamus the shortstop
here's the o2 to adamus and he gets a
looking and degrom strikes out the side
on 10 pitches in the first inning that's
an impressive way to begin well making
the open here tonight is going to be
right-hander pete fairbanks the second
time that he has done that this season
overall a lot of decisions for what
mainly his a bullpen guy five and three
on the record good era so with two outs
and a runner at first base no score here
in the bottom of the first
runner goes the pitch is down and the
throw
they're gonna get him he is out at
second base
and that retires the side adamus the
shortstop took the throw and the mets
are done in the first head off walk here
in the second so here's joey wendell one
on nobody out
he strokes it into left center field
that's going to be in there extra bases
mcneal plays the carrum
low will turn third and hang on there he
got yeah very fortunate there it looked
nate lowe coming around third base was
going to try and score he got held up
late
fly ball back into center field heredia
lining up to make the catch tagged by
low
he heads to the plate the throw heads to
third and the rays have the first run of
the game here's mike zanino hitting
ninth in the order first and third and
two out one another zenino there goes
the runner no throw by ramos and it's a
stolen base for phillips
his sixth stolen base of the year the
grom is not happy with home plate umpire
land
larry van over
[Applause]
and you can hear van over clear as a
bell
saying we're not doing that oh yes we
are and they'll be doing it all night
long 2-2 coming and he's struck out
again
five strikeouts for de grome in the
first two innings but the rays put up a
run yoshi tsutsugo leading off in the
third
and he goes down on the change up so
tsugo is struck out for the second time
that's six now for degrom he has 86
strikeouts for the year and he has
fanned the first two here in the third
and now williams will back brom through
his wind up left leg kick 3-2 pitch
swinging a missed strike three it was a
darting slider down and away adam has
chased it and jacob degrom has struck
out the side for the second time in
three innings tonight
he's going to lead things off and jacob
degrom this is the stretch of the lineup
where he had a little trouble with him
in a second
into center field
pretty well tagged and that one is going
to get out of here home run
off the bat of nate lowe
he got under that a little backspin and
carried that one right out of here to
center his fourth home run and the rays
have a two-nothing lead
hold down to first nice diving stop by
don from his knees and degrom reaches up
nicely to complete the play it almost
let jacob a little bit too much well
that tested the hamstring and that'll
bring up yoshi 3-2 from degrom to
sugo struck him out
number 10 for degrom 45th time in his
career he's had 10 or more and the first
time in men's history they've had three
starters strike out 10 in three
consecutive games fleming had retired
the first two a walk a single and a hit
batsman and now jeff mcneal the hottest
hitter the mets have right now is gonna
bat with the bases loaded
and jeff hits one toward the middle and
adonis got a piece of it but he has no
play and a run comes home adamus saved
her run by smothering it but had no play
so it's an infield hit from mcneil to
bring in horadia and cut the tampa bay
lead to 2-1 now lao is at third and nate
lowe swings the bat very well we saw him
homer earlier
got him number 12 for degrom and a big
one pinning low at third now there are
two down this is number 99 coming up
and wendell pulls it and dom bobbles but
it comes right to the bare hand and
degrom covers that saves a run and ends
the inning jacob degrom coming back out
for the seventh inning he was at 99
pitches through six
and kiermeier goes down swinging and
that is 13 strikeouts for jacob degrom
one shy of his career high just anything
above the letters this this team can't
catch up with it 2-2 to phillips
breaking ball struck him out number 14
for degrom he matches his career high
14 strikeouts in seven innings for jacob
degrom
right-hander nick anderson comes on to
pitch for the raise as we go to the
bottom of the ninth inning anderson the
sixth tampa bay pitcher of the night
they've all done well canoe is over
three tonight pitch number 11.
and a fly ball back into center field
kirameyer is going to have room and
makes the catch as he stepped onto the
warning track he got it now the mets are
down to their final out the pinch
he pops him up off the fastball left
side
joey wendell making the call right there
in front of adamus and wendell makes the
catch and the raves win this one it's a
2-1 final and the rays reduce their
magic number to two to clinch the
division